We have to buy my grandma a new pan
Please leave that in the video
Hey guys I'm Nate. I'm Zack from the YouTube channel JerryRigEverything
Today we're back at the dome and we're gonna be doing a few experiments that involve lithium batteries in some molten aluminum
And one of those batteries is still inside of this iPhone. We've got our aluminum. We've got our furnace. Let's get started
This is why I like filming inside the dome. That doesn't look half as good when you're outside
All right our furnace is nice and hot, our aluminum is nice and melted down inside
Zach what's the plan?
So we have some lithium batteries that we're gonna toss in the aluminum because lithium is very reactive
And I'm excited to see what happens with that
But I also have this iPhone here in one of my previous videos that has a bunch of scratch marks on it
I scratched it up with diamonds because the diamonds are super hard level ten on Most scale one thing
I'm curious about though is that the back of this iPhone is made from aluminum
And I'm curious to see how that reacts with the molten aluminum inside of the furnace. So we'll take our crucible out...
We'll set it on the rock and then Zach is going to be putting his iPhone down inside the melted aluminum
We'll see if it survives or not
I bet it doesn't
All right
Yeah, I'd say now just drop it in and run away
Oh [laughs]. It's sick.
Oh looks good
Is the screen still working? I doubt it [laughs] though it went off very quickly. [laughs]
That is sweet I did not expect the outer aluminium to catch fire
I wonder if it's like the... It's anodized so that might be doing it. The anodizing? Yeah.
I don't know what that process and chemical is, but that's probably more flamable than raw aluminium. Yeah
Aw dude, the whole thing's melting
That's almost like a sweet smell to it... Ooh, the camera lens is on fire
All right Zach now you get to fix it.
[Zach] Yeah...
You have a tutorial on how to repair this?
What we've got here is an iPhone that has been burned to a crisp
Everywhere half of the back melted off and pooled into our aluminum
That was already in the crucible
And we've just exposed and destroyed all of the internal workings of it one interesting thing is that the glass lens right here well
Sapphire lens of the iPhone is drizzled out and it's melted all over the upper part of the aluminum panel
So that's you can see that how it melted their sapphire
Is that low of a melting point? so Apple Sapphire isn't as pure as regular sapphire, okay
I did some tests on that on my channel
But that would be curious to see what the melting point of sapphire actually is
Because I mean aluminum has its temperature it does
And then all of the glass on the screen is now gone as well, so you can see the aluminum back plate of the screen
That's sitting between the LCD and the internals of the phone
But as far as the glass goes on the front gone.
On the back one thing that I thought was curious since we're dipping
lithium-ion batteries inside of aluminum the pouch style batteries that are inside of iPhones have
Different anode cathode layers to them and you can see all these layers holding up and around
the battery itself.
Which is interesting that
These survived while the aluminum panel didn't it's similar to the other lithium batteries that we're gonna try putting in the aluminum
They have the same idea except. They're rolled up circular coil yeah.
One iPhone completely destroyed by being half submerged into molten aluminum now
Let's move on to trying our other lithium batteries and see what happens with those in similar situations
All right, we've got our aluminum heated back up, and we've got some of these lithium batteries
And we're gonna try dropping those into our crucible, so I'm gonna drop mine in negative side first
And he's gonna drop his positive side first aluminum is conductive this amount of voltage probably won't do anything
But it's worth a shot one other thing
I'm curious about is what this shell on the outside the battery is made of if it's aluminum
It should dissolve just like the iPhone case did
But if it's steel or something else it should remain intact right it might be steel, but I'm not positive
Only one way to find out
That looks sweet you can see the glowing bits inside
There's not as much slag as I thought that would be I think probably a lot of stuff has burned up and
It's possible some stuff. That's not so flammable has fallen to the bottom
true
One two drop.
[Explosion] oh shoot [laughs]
What in the world dude, it's like a sparkler
It's like one of those fountain things you light up on the 4th of July. That's amazing.
No, wait it's exactly like a firework. That is so cool. Ohh
See I've burned lithium batteries before, I kind of knew what it was gonna do I had no idea what that was gonna end like.
was great
Looks like that's both of them it exploded both women everywhere. I'm out. Oh
Oh One of the batteries missed it might have been mine, I didn't see mine splash you knows what I was running away
Oh, I'm not sure one of us failed replay the slow-motion. Yep, all right your turn
Nice it's in its flaming it's gonna pop!
And now
We'll get to the second stage where it where it sparkles, sparks and...
Jet of, I wish the iPhone would have done that that was sweet Jet of pink fire
That's epic so if your carcass is still in the molten aluminum right so the explosion was probably just the carcass splitting
let's tear this open and see like what exactly what happened with the heat I
Don't think the shell is aluminum in otherwise it would have melted
Yeah, all right
So it looks like just one of the ends
blew out on both of these this it's a positive side or the negative side?
I think it's the positive side that breaks off because I've dismantled these before and they have sort of a cap on the positive side
Underneath the wrapper so you can kind of see the cap right here
That was pretty sweet dropping those batteries down into the crucible, but I think we can go more. Don't you?
We might as well, so we've got a whole bunch of these batteries left
We're gonna try throwing them into this pot pan pan
And then we're gonna pour our molten aluminum all over them and hopefully they'll all ignite who's doing the pouring you or me?
How brave do you feel? I think you should be doing the pouring I'll be doing the pouring perfect all right.
Cool that is
Toasty I see that probably every time it always impresses me when it's glowing orange like that
Alright, so I would say you have like probably five seconds before six explosions start tossing molten aluminum your direction
That is probably very true
So I will definitely try to pour and back off as fast as I can I'm gonna go stand over here
Away from you. That's a good choice
three! two! one!
Oh it spilled out of the container alot, yeah boiled over one two three five
I Lost track I think that's five
They should start hissing here, that's six
This is amazing its just like a firework show well that was a bit too close that was at least 15 feet that was quite a shot ohh
That was more like 25 feet
That was the finale right there that went off and that was the end Wow one final big explosion that was great
Ha Ha
A whole bunch of battery carcasses
And again still something worth quite a bit of liquid in fact. That's aluminum for you with it's very high specific heat
It does not like to transition easily between one state and another
That was beautiful.
Got a big chunk out.
We've still got some some nice pink flame here. I think that's some of the lithium still burning right there. That's sort of magenta color
Lithium batteries dropped into molten aluminum sometimes inside an iPhone.
It worked out pretty well, The reaction was much more intense with the batteries themselves, but it was still it shouldn't see what's inside of an iPhone
Using metal to dissolve the metal around it really not the most conventional way to open up a phone
And I think it's probably a little beyond all repair. Yeah even for him, but that was a lot of fun.
We got some great and almost violent reactions from those lithium batteries exploding the last one especially it shot sparks
25 feet those pretty nuts fortunately it didn't seem to send any molten aluminum flying it was just like little bits of sparks
From the batteries themselves, but it looked really cool.
Hey guys
Thanks for watching if you're not a subscriber
Yet hit the bomb to get in the club! If you missed our last video
Or you want to watch it again click up here at the top
Click down there if you want to see what the internet thinks you should watch next
That's it for now. Have fun. Be safe. See you tomorrow.